>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
[ Silence ]
>> John Cole: Well, good
afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to the Library of Congress.
I'm John Cole.
Up until this week, I was the
director of the Center for the Book
in the Library of Congress, which
was created by Daniel Boorstin
when he was librarian
and way back in 1977.
You're going to get a little
reminiscing here today
at this session.
I am now the -- this is my first
week as officially the first Library
of Congress official historian.
So I'm pleased to make that change,
because for many years I've been
very interested in all parts
of the Library of Congress
and its history.
And I also started my career in CRS.
So we have a special
welcome to CRS and some
of his chiefs and assistant chiefs.
One of the ironies in this -- and
I don't see -- Pam, are you here?
The person who's taking
my place is the director
of the Center for the Book.
Pam Jackson will be
in a little later.
The Center for the Book was created
in 1977 to stimulate -- to have --
Daniel Boorstin felt the
Library should do more
for the general public
in stimulating interest
in books and reading.
And there should be -- and it was a
private public partnership created
by publishers, funded
in the beginning
with eventually the Library of
Congress picking up the salaries
of the Center as it grew.
So today we are a partnership
that includes both the new Young
Readers Center, which is located
in -- not new anymore, 2009,
located in the Jefferson Building.
The Poetry and Literature Office is
now part of the Center for the Book.
The National Book Festival
is an area
where we've played a major
role since the beginning.
But here at LC, one of the favorite
programs has been the one you're
attending today.
And these are Books and
Beyond talks about new books
that have been published based on --
and that have a special connection
with the Library of Congress.
And often it's based
on our collections,
and other times it's
based on projects.
And we also make a point
of promoting the Library
of Congress's publications.
And when we -- as the
publishing office comes
out with books, we provide a forum.
All of these talks are filmed for
the Library of Congress website,
and they started in 1996.
And so we are approaching
400 of these talks,
which really give you the
slice of American scholarship,
and also books related to
institutions, not just the Library
of Congress, but primarily
the Library of Congress.
And so it's been successful, and
we're pleased that you are here.
The format will be a presentation,
in this case, by Steve Hess,
then a quick opportunity
for questions and answers,
and a book signing
here in this room.
And the books are on sale for the
Library of Congress staff discount,
which is ten percent off.
As I said, the programs are
being filmed, and so we are --
please turn off all
things electronic.
And we also will close the doors
since we have some noise outside.
I want to just one
more story, actually,
relating to my early history.
When I got interested in the
history of the Library of Congress,
I was able to move into a position
in the old Collection Development
Office, because I knew I needed
to learn about collections.
And one of the very first curators
I met -- and this was in --
it would have been 1968,
actually, as I was making the move
into the Library as a whole,
was a wonderful man named Milton
Kaplan [assumed spelling].
And he was the curator, among other
things, a prince, a political prince
at the Library of Congress.
And in 1968, I met Milton, and
he had just published a book
with a fellow named "Stephen Hess",
and it was called "The
Ungentlemanly Art:
A History of American Political
Cartoons", which is another side
of Steve's many interests
related to politics.
And it was eventually -- and
Steve doesn't remember this,
but it was through
Milton that we met.
But Steve also then later
produced a book called
"American Political Cartoons: The
Evolution of a National Identity".
And you came here for a book talk
with your coauthor, Sandy Northrop.
And this is a very handy book now
in paperback, which I'm also going
to try to have you sign as part
of my Stephen Hess collection.
[Laughter] Stephen is right --
currently is a senior fellow
emeritus in government studies,
that's a wonderful moniker,
at the Brookings Institution.
He began his career in
Washington as a young speechwriter
for President Dwight Eisenhower,
who members in this audience,
most of you will remember, but
for some of the younger ones,
was President from 1958 to 1961.
Steve also served on the staff of
President Nixon and was an advisor
to Presidents Gerald
Ford and Jimmy Carter.
He also has been professor
of media and public studies
at George Washington University,
and has published many
books on many topics.
The most recent one that we talked
about a little bit was based
on the Moynihan Papers here
at the Library of Congress,
and it was a biography
of Mr. Moynihan.
As I mentioned that I
met Steve through books
and political cartoons,
another part of his world.
And we're just so pleased
that he can be here today.
The procedure is after
the questions and answers,
we will have a book signing.
And that needs to start by
1:00, so there will be time
for Q&A, though, as well.
Here is the book we're celebrating,
and here is the first sentence
in this 760-page revision
of his earlier book,
"America's Political Dynasties
from Adams to Clinton".
Here is how he starts it actually
in the Acknowledgement page.
"If there was to have been a Rip
Van Winkle moment in my life,
it would have been in February
2015 when I awoke with the desire
to rewrite 'America's Political
Dynasties', a book I had put
to bed a half a century earlier."
I will let him take it from here.
Please welcome Stephen Hess.
[ Applause ]
I'll take my book off
so you don't --
>> Stephen Hess: Okay.
>> John Cole: Stumble [inaudible].
>> Stephen Hess: John, it is always
such a pleasure to
be introduced by you.
[Laughs] It always reminds me
of President Eisenhower's
favorite cartoon
from the old Saturday Evening
Post, which showed a man stand
like this saying, "Our next speaker
needs all the introduction he
can get."
[Laughter] And even
talking about my monitor,
I worry about introductions,
not with John, but otherwise.
I was going to give a talk
in Athens some years ago,
and thought maybe I had best get
my resume translated into Greek.
So when I went over there
and gave it to the person
who would introduce me, who of
course, spoke perfect English,
and he looked at what I gave
him, and he said, "Mr. Hess,
what is your title at Brookings?"
And I said, "Senior fellow; senior."
He said, "Oh, yes, it's been
translated as 'Ancient gentleman'."
[Laughter] So I'm here today as
an ancient gentleman emeritus.
And of course, I always wanted
to connect my books and so forth
to the Library, and
this one particularly
because all the research 50
years ago was done right here.
But John mentioned my
connection with Milton Kaplan.
So the Library actually went back
to the first book I ever wrote,
which was called "Hats in the Ring."
In 1959, it had come
out by Random House.
The problem was it
was a little thin.
And I figured I'd better get some
cartoons to make it more weighty.
And I came over here, and
met this very nice man
who was very helpful, Milton Kaplan.
And in the course of the friendship,
he said, "Well, you know,
there had never been a history
of American political cartoons."
And that started me in a
whole different career,
which was great, great fun.
Because my affection for
the Center for the Book,
I thought I would talk a little
differently than I usually talk
in a bookstore about any
book in which I tell people,
particularly a summary of
everything that's in it
so they don't have
to buy it, you know?
I really want to talk a bit more
about the history of the book,
because in some ways
it's also my history.
[ Silence ]
The book really goes back to 1957
right outside Frankfurt, Germany.
And I am a private, drafted
into the United States Army.
And it's peace time.
And I go to the Library
to look for a book.
Actually, I started to look for
a civil war book at the moment.
And I find instead
this massive thing --
I weighed it later it was
seven-and-a-half pounds,
which is called "The
Biographical Directory
of the United States
Congress from 1774".
I knew a little -- I'd been
a political science major
at Johns Hopkins, I knew a
little about American history.
I knew about the Adams, of course,
the Roosevelts, Tafts, Harrisons.
But as I just started to
skim through this book,
there it was Muhlenberg, Muhlenberg,
Muhlenberg, Muhlenberg, Muhlenberg,
Bayard [phonetic], Bayard, Bayard,
Bayard, Tucker, Tucker, Tucker,
Tucker, Stockton, Stockton,
Stockton, Frelinghuysen,
all of these names that really
meant very -- nothing to me.
And yet, there I was looking at a
book that showed that generation
after generation, they had been
sent to the United States Congress.
And I thought that was
rather interesting,
particularly since our
Constitution has a clause
about nobility, clause of nobility.
So the Army and peacetime Army
in the evenings when I wasn't
on guard duty or something, I
would go and start genealogies.
And by the time, two years,
1958, when I was released
and my successor -- oh God, who was
it, what was it, he was a singer.
What was his name?
>> Elvis.
>>
>> Stephen Hess: Elvis Presley,
that was the fellow, he replaced me
as a matter of fact;
it's almost true.
[Laughter] He didn't replace my
unit and his unit, he replaced --
but it was his unit
replaced by my unit.
And there I came home with 300
genealogies, and the thought
that these were really
quite interesting.
It was just something
that had not been
in American textbooks typically,
that someday I would
write a book about it.
But I was an unemployed
private in August.
And then a very strange
thing happened.
Several weeks later, I was the
president's number two speechwriter.
Now, that's pretty hard to
do at 25, and it all happens
because my mentor, Johns Hopkins,
and Malcolm Moos had
just been appointed,
literally just been
appointed the speechwriter.
And so the president and
-- brought me into this.
Later when I had students of my
own, they'd say, "How do you get
to be the president's
speechwriter at 25?"
I said, "Be very nice
to your professor."
[Laughter] And I stayed there until
the end of the administration,
January 20th, 1961, when I --
gosh I was unemployed again.
And at that time the president,
about to be the ex-president got
into his old car, and was driven
back to his home in Gettysburg,
where Gettysburg College gave him
some room to make his memoirs.
Totally different; they didn't
have a law then that provided all
of the housing, all of the
offices, all of the staff,
all of the security that we
now give a former president.
He didn't have that at all.
And the Republican National
Committee said to themselves,
and then to me, "If we're going
to keep this fellow
visible politically,
somebody has to answer his mail.
Would you be interested?"
Otherwise, unemployed, "Sure."
The problem with that, of course,
is we had no idea what
we were talking about.
So we wrote a contract that
was based on each letter.
And I think initially I was to
get three dollars for each letter.
What we didn't realize
there wasn't just a letter,
there was a deluge of letters.
This was the most popular man
in the world, two-time president
of the United States,
five-star general.
Every high school kid
wanted his opinion
on the national debate topic.
Churches wanted something
for their bazaars.
People wanted his autograph,
or his picture;
people just wanted to say hello.
The answer to that is that after
two years, I had a lot of money.
But I should [laughter] say also I
did learn something at the moment.
They were not just people who wanted
his pictures, there were a lot
of people who were very sick people
who were making threats on his life.
And that's the first time I realized
that there were people out there
that we didn't all know very well.
And I called the Secret Service
and they said, "Oh, yes."
And they sent me a three-ring
binder, and they said, you know,
"If anybody's name
isn't in it, call us up,
and we'll put the name in there."
Okay; I now have a wife, I have
children, and about three years
in which I can do what
I really want to do,
and that is write a book called,
"America's Political Dynasties".
I'm not an academic of any sort.
So the thing to do is to
go the Library of Congress
and take advantage of the
generosity of all of the librarians
and staff here, which
I really, really did,
often in some collections
bringing in an ancient --
but first of reproducing
a machine that weighed --
it was supposed to be portable,
well it weighed about 15 pounds.
And they allowed me to put it
on some papers and reproduce
on some little sheet of
paper that it was chemically,
turned sort of pink and folded
at the edges, but it was better
than writing it all in my hand.
And the book came out.
The book really was simply
meant to be the stories
of these remarkable
people, and of this fact,
which was not terribly significant
in the sense that of those
that one could call a dynasty,
three generations, four generations
and so forth, they only
amounted to six percent of those
who had served -- of the
11,000 who had served
in the United States Congress.
But they were interesting
stories, at any rate.
Of course, what happened,
then, as I wrote the book,
is that other family came along
that were very interesting
called the Kennedys,
who were not there initially
when I started to write the book.
But we made room for them, and
the book was very well-received
and a best-seller, and
it was something else.
I mean, remember, I had somehow
become successful in a line --
an occupation which is
not really what I wanted
to be or where I wanted to be.
I wanted to -- well I wanted I
guess if I had my choice to start
over to be a senior fellow
at the Brookings Institution.
So in a funny way, this book,
bestseller, turned out to be my --
I had no PhD, my PhD, and which
I presented to Brookings myself.
Brookings, at that
time, was a place --
most of hiring in the
United States had to do
with people just circling each other
until they were sure they liked
each, other rather than filling
out applications and giving
speeches, and so forth.
So indeed that's -- the book played
a rather unique personal part
of my history.
Okay; we're now 50 years later.
And I'm thinking, "Wouldn't
it be interesting to put
out a new edition, because 2016 is
going to be a big dynasties year."
It's going to be the
Bushs versus the Clintons.
We all -- [inaudible] told us that.
Brookings, my publishers thought
that was a very good idea.
And I set out with the
idea that the book,
which was basically
16 family stories --
it's interesting in the fact
as Matthews [inaudible] said you
could kill somebody with this book.
But in fact, it's really 16 books.
Each of these families could
be read quite individually.
And so I would have to add two
families and a new introduction.
The two families would be Bush
family, who were a dynasty,
but denied that they were
dynasty, and the Clinton family,
who aren't a dynasty but were
desperate to be a dynasty,
and so we had to add those.
And then each chapter would just --
at the end of the chapter
of the other 16 families --
now other 18, would be what had
happened in the last 50 years.
So I thought it would
be very easy to write.
Adams family, nothing happened.
They hadn't been around for 150
years; until I started to research,
and again, the Adams family maybe
hadn't been around for 50 years,
but historians had been
around for 50 years,
and the Adams have a family
that filed every piece
of paper that they ever saw.
And there was a whole new even
Adams history or histiography
by the time 50 years later,
I wanted to write this book
that had to be considered.
Particularly, in my judgment,
Abigail, who is my favorite
of the group, who had
a far better strategic
and tactical sense
politically than her husband --
the Constitution had been rewritten,
she should have been the president
of the United States; she
would have done a better job.
At any rate, here's
what's in the a part --
a little sentence or two
about Abigail that wasn't
in the first edition, because
we didn't know about it
in the first edition, but
some historians since told us.
Abigail was a very
good business woman.
John had gone off to
France during the revolution
to represent us in Europe.
And she was left there
with the family in a farm.
Running the farm was
not going to be easy,
because most of the men
had gone off to war,
and taxes were very
high to pay for the war.
But she figured out a way to
divide it up in such a way
and have tending farmers,
and she did that.
But that wasn't her whole
history as a business woman.
John would send her a silk
scarf, silk handkerchief.
You know, whenever he knew somebody
was coming across the Atlantic,
he'd say, "Hey Lafayette, would
you bring my wife a silk scarf,"
[laughter] that sort of thing.
And she, of course, made a deal
with the merchant and would sell it.
These were very valuable here.
We didn't have a lot of silk scarves
running around in Massachusetts.
And then she said to --
wrote to her husband --
literally wrote to her
husband, "John, we're in retail.
We should be in wholesale."
And he said, "Wholesale; how --
you know, all of our
ships are being captured.
We can't do just -- " and she said
-- and she wrote him and said,
"John, if two of the
three ships are captured,
we will still make a profit."
And so he says, "Sounds like
she knows her business."
So it became retail, at
which point, of course,
she now could judge the stock,
"We have too many scarves.
We need some more handkerchiefs,"
or whatever it is.
And she was the one -- John
never had an employer other
than the United States government
for the rest of his life.
She was the one who turned the
solvency of the Adams family.
Now, that's a story here that
wasn't in the book 50 years ago.
And it was like that.
Fifty years ago, as I said, the
book was a good story to tell,
a little bit of American
history that people didn't know.
When I started to rewrite the book,
and the book became
40% new material,
I realized that I was
telling America's history
through the family.
And families, all families,
your family, my family,
are fascinating, mysterious.
It was a great vehicle to tell
the history of the United States,
which otherwise is usually told
by who's elected, and the people
that are elected are all males.
A family can't be all males.
So suddenly as I reread what
I had written 50 years ago,
I could see I was telling stories
about the men, and the women,
the wives, the sons, the
daughters, the in-laws and so forth.
There was very different way
to look at the United States.
Also, it became different
-- as I went through it --
these families, how they became
dynasties is pretty obvious.
You know, they had
ambition, they had energy,
they wanted a good job,
whatever it might be.
How they left politics was
all individual and different,
and I thought became, in some
way, a more interesting story.
For example, the Adams's.
[ Background Sounds ]
I'll get that later.
The Adam's had several explanations
for their political demise.
John Adams might even have contended
that it was a planned exodus
to hire forms of cultural
expression.
While serving as militia diplomat
in France, he wrote Abigail,
"I must study politics and war
that my sons may have liberty
to study mathematics and philosophy.
My sons are to study mathematics
and philosophy in order
to give their children a right
to study painting, poetry,
music, and architecture."
[Laughter] This theory
of politics to poetry
and three generations turns out
to be almost exactly the history
of the Adams family,
as a matter of fact.
But there are about more complicated
reasons for that, in the opinion
of Brooks Adams who would
be Henry Adams' brother.
"A single family can stay adjusted
through three generations,"
and then added, "It is
now four full generations
since John Adams wrote the
Constitution of Massachusetts.
It is a time that we perish.
The world is tired of us."
Some people may say that
about the Bush's today, right,
that the world is tired of us.
The family -- and other
problems, too,
Henry and Brooks didn't
have children,
although there were children around.
So it helps -- and many of these
dynasties have huge numbers
of children as well.
But really, you put it altogether.
First of all, in the third
generation, Charles Francis Adams,
he married the daughter of
the richest man in Boston.
And now the family was rich.
And you always think in
politics that's good,
but it also gave the
Adams's, like Henry Adams.
a chance to do other things
other than be in politics.
And it really did turn
the arch of the Adams's.
But really, when you
read the whole chapter
and you see these characters
-- and they were rather rude,
rather unpleasant people.
And it's clear that
Americans no longer
as we became a larger electric, not
just an electric for men with means,
we wanted somebody other than these
rude, odd people, the Adams's.
And so we turned from the
Adams's in a funny way.
So that was good.
But then if you take another
family, a very famous family,
the Livingstons of the Revolutionary
War period, we were full of them.
And the exact opposite happened with
them, in which I write at the end,
"The death of the dynasty
was self-inflicted.
They were not tired by the people,
they tired from the people."
And it goes on and as historian
George [inaudible] put it,
"They did not wish to condescend to
the demands of popular politics."
So they went back to their
estates, at high-end New York.
They married each other.
They stopped -- they went
out of entrepreneurial work,
and they became sort of
a Shinto type of family.
So when the Adams's, their people
rejected them, the Livingstons,
they rejected the people --
the chapter that goes
between the Livingstons
and the Adams's is
actually the Lees.
And when you think about it,
the founders of our country,
the two great families that
created the revolution,
were the Adams's and the Lees.
And the Adams's were such poor
farmers; they had nothing.
You read the estate that the first
Henry Adams left, you know, a farm,
a bed, you know, a
shed and so forth.
Then, you read the
estate of the first Lees,
13,000 acres of rich tobacco
land, and so forth and so on.
And the Lees -- after a while
Robert E. Lee, who had --
the greatest general, now by the
time you get to a fifth generation,
actually to his grandson,
whose name was "Fitzhugh Lee",
and he was the commandant
of the naval war college,
and you start to see that all of
the Lees are now in the military;
and their daughters are all
marrying admirals and generals.
And this goes on generation
after generation.
The heirs of Fitzhugh Lee
formed an unusual record
of occupational consistency.
His two sons became
cavalry officers.
[ Background Sounds ]
His three daughters married
army officers, all generals.
And on and on it goes to that
right up to World War II.
So the Lees stayed as a dynasty, but
they became a political dynasty --
I mean, excuse me, they
became a military dynasty,
another type of public service,
which was very interesting.
So as you go through it, there
really are very interesting changes.
The Breckenridges were
a passionate family.
God, they could fight over anything
among themselves from Kentucky.
They're the most famous --
John C. Brackenridge was vice
president of the United States.
And what happens to them, in effect,
was after the civil war there wasn't
any room for them in Kentucky.
It was poor by now,
if these ambitious
and very talented people
went -- left the state.
And as they left the
state, they left their base.
Many of these families, you
realize, are the Tafts of Ohio,
that sort of thing; the
Frelinghuysen's of New Jersey.
So usually, they had base, unless
there were too many of them
and they would sort of overwhelm the
base so that you have the Kennedys
of Massachusetts, Connecticut,
Rhode Island, Maryland,
New York, and that sort of thing.
But typically, the
Breckenridges lost their bases
as they left Kentucky.
But again, such fascinating things.
The part I love -- this is a
little longer than I usually read,
but it's such a great story.
It's John C. Breckenridge, after
leaving the vice presidency
of the United States and
joining the Confederacy,
becoming a distinguished
military service,
and then he becomes the final
secretary of war of the Confederacy.
And then in the final days, he
tries to convince Jefferson Davis,
you know, "Let's just end this.
It's been a magnificent
epic, but it's got to stop.
No more." And a Confederate
cabinet begins the flight
from Richmond in April 2, 1965.
And for the secretary of war
it begins a two-month adventure
that reads like a Viking
romance point of reality.
He takes the Southern
underground, the party goes as far
through Virginia and the Carolinas.
When they get to Charlotte,
they get the news
of the assassination of Lincoln.
He immediately sends
his entourage home.
He doesn't want any
more killed for this.
He continues on with his aide
and a black servant as they --
and then they pick
up a couple others
so that they're a party
of about eight.
And this begins the Viking romance.
"As they pass through the high
saw grass of the Everglades,
it struck Breckenridge that
if a man had his arms tied
and his feet exposed, he would be
killed by insects in two nights.
By the time they were living on
the eggs of huge green turtles,
which they had dug out of the sand.
Once they had spotted
a union steamer,
but they'd bluffed their way
out by pretending they
were hunters and wreckers.
Early on in the morning of June 6th,
the hungry Confederates met a party
of Seminole Indians, and
were given some [inaudible],
which he describes
as a thick pancake.
They also scrounged a few
bits of fish that were left
over from the Indians' breakfast.
At the sight of Del Ray, the
Confederate secretary of war
and his aides turned pirate and
took over a sloop at gunpoint.
On June 8th, they left
the keys for Cuba.
The waves on the high sea were
20 feet high, and their legs
and arms became blistered and
swollen from the heat and saltwater.
Finally, on June 11th, 1865,
the former vice president
of the United States arrived
75 miles east of Atlanta."
So America is just a great
history of great stories.
I love them all.
So you go on -- how
am I doing, John?
>> [Inaudible] some Q&A.
>> Stephen Hess: We're at Q&As.
Enough of this odds and
ends; serious to Q&As.
[ Applause ]
[ Silence ]
Well, I'll continue reading.
[Laughter] Oh, my.
[ Inaudible Comments ]
Oh, yes, that, okay what do you do
with the Clintons who
aren't a dynasty?
Well, you start by saying
they'll become a dynasty
when their granddaughter, Charlotte,
becomes 25, the youngest she can run
from Congress for the
House of Representatives,
and if she's elected, that
qualifies them not only as dynasty,
but especially since Chelsea is
married to a man whose both father
and mother had been in Congress.
So she's going to be a part of what
I call a mixed-marriage dynasty.
But basically, what I do is this --
and again, it was hard to write a
chapter on the Clintons quickly,
or the Bushs when so
much has been written.
I reinterpret them as a partnership;
not as a dynasty, as a partnership.
And when you use that, you start
going right back to Yale Law School,
and it is such a clear pattern that
runs through their lives together.
Partnerships are -- could
be complicated, successful,
have their problems, and so forth.
But that is generally
how I take them.
Of course, ending with Chelsea,
who I found quite fascinating.
I mean, Chelsea has a
bachelors degree from Stanford,
she has a masters degree from
Columbia, she has a PhD from Oxford,
she's pretty powerful
and thoughty woman.
So, you know, the question
is, "What does she do
with the rest of her life?"
And she has various options,
including, of course,
the Clinton Foundation, which
is quite an amazing operation
as you start to look
into what it is.
And partly, it's what happens --
just partly the Clinton history,
to people who aren't rich, but
are in a world of the rich.
How do you do it?
And their foundation was
not Bill Gates' foundation.
It was something in which
they found projects,
and then encouraged vast
rich people to fund them.
So they're really all
over the world.
But it's an interesting --
and it has her name on it.
Maybe she goes that way,
maybe she goes into politics.
That's it.
The Bush family was hard to write
about in the same way, I should add.
I wrote a little about the
Founding Father, the congressman
because he's not -- a senator,
he's not as well known.
But mostly, it looked at
the Bush group going back
through two presidents
and another governor.
What was unusual about them was
that they all lost elections
before they won elections.
The persistence of them
was really quite amazing.
And if you're rich, as they were,
it's easy enough to turn around
and go into something else, dig
another oil well, or what have you,
but no, they kept at it
right up to, of course,
the point where I was writing.
And then I wrote a little -- this
sort of riddle, of the fact that all
of these families, who were the
presidential families, who had one
or two, but clearly
wanted more, lost.
And that was -- we were going
to see how that worked out.
So that's how I dealt
with those two families.
There was another -- yes.
>> So would you say that a de facto
nobility has emerged in the US?
>> John Cole: [Inaudible] repeat --
>> Stephen Hess: Yes;
has a nobility risen?
If it is, it's a self-rising
nobility because, of course,
all these people who we are talking
about it could be defeated
at the next election.
2014 half a dozen big names from the
Senate and the House were defeated.
So they live on that edge.
But nevertheless, the name
is worth something, branded,
clearly, and for other reasons.
What I generally said when
we got to the Roosevelts,
or at least the Franklins --
the Delano Roosevelt family,
he had two sons who
chose to continue
in politics, James and Franklin.
Both of them were elected
from relatively safe seats,
one in California,
and one in New York.
Each then chose to go for a higher
office, and each was defeated.
So in general, my rule of thumb was
that a good name was worth one step
up the ladder, and then
you were on your own.
And certainly, that was true
of the Roosevelt family.
So that would be my more or
less answer to your question.
[ Silence ]
By the way, I'll add in one
more, a normative answer,
because I've now spend a lot of
time going through a lot of names
that are connected to each other.
I think by and large, they've
given us above-average service.
I mean, I'm not going to make
claims for the Longs [phonetic]
of Louisiana or something like that.
But overall, I think we've been
well-enough served by them.
[ Silence ]
Yes.
>> So it sounds like you
didn't do a statistical survey,
but do you have a sense of whether
the United States is trending
a direction?
You said -- I think you
talked about a [inaudible].
>> Stephen Hess: No;
I haven't done that.
Of course, when I wrote --
started to write the second book,
the big question was were
we having government legacy?
And clearly, we've already
figured out that we're not.
And I think that's correct.
No; there was no special
purpose for me to do it.
It wasn't political [inaudible].
I didn't break it into
judgments, but I counted them all.
And to me -- and you
compare them all,
they tended all to be Protestants.
With the exception of the Kennedys
and one branch of the Bushes,
they tended to be rich or at
least rich when they ended,
if not rich when they started.
They did move -- although as
I say, they started on the --
obviously on the East Coast.
They did continue to move west.
They were ambitious in that sense.
The Harrisons, for instance,
were a major Virginia family
when they started, and went
to Indiana, went to Illinois,
and the last one was in Wyoming.
So there was a great -- they
cover the whole country now.
They're not particularly an
East Coast pattern anymore.
So I did look at things in that way.
They did, as I mentioned, with the
third generation of the Adams's,
is one of the big ways that they
got their money was they married it.
They had some very
advantageous marriages.
The Frelinghuysen there's one
still in Congress right now,
who is the great, great, great,
great, great, great grandson
of the person who first
stepped foot on the land
in New Jersey that
he now represents.
And it's been -- well and
they've not been a particularly
distinguished family in that regard,
but they serve their
constituents at least.
And then you look at
who they married.
Well, generation marries
a Ballantine.
Who's Ballantine; well, Ballantine
ale, Ballantine brew, not bad.
The next generation, his daughter
-- or son marries a Havemeyer.
That's the sugar trust.
That's much bigger than Ballantine.
And the next generation marries
somebody named "Procter",
who just happens to be the
Procter of Procter & Gamble.
So the money keeps coming in.
By the way, the one -- the son now,
his name is "Rodney", his father,
Peter, was in Congress when
I wrote the book initially,
I knew him modestly because we were
both part of a tiny group of people
who were called, you know,
"Liberal Republicans" at the time.
And he never spoke to
me again after that.
This was [inaudible],
people did not talk
about where the money came from.
He was very upset by that.
But that was another factor that
you'll look at in judging them,
as they say, and having a lot
of children was one as well.
So that's the sort
of things I tracked,
rather than how many existed at
each period of American history.
>> Did you describe the Kennedys;
and then also the Dingles
[phonetic]?
>> Stephen Hess: I don't
include the Dingles.
The Dingles would now
be father, son,
and daughter and wife, and so forth.
The Kennedys I certainly
do describe.
The Kennedys would have been
the one family if I had stuck
to my original scheme of just
saying, "Okay; what have you done
in the last 50 years,"
there would be a lot.
Since then there have been -- "them"
being, of course John Kennedy,
Robert Kennedy, Ted Kennedy.
There had been additionally
Ted's son from Rhode Island.
But also then, John F.
Kennedy, son of Robert Kennedy,
and then John F. Kennedy,
the son of John F. Kennedy.
So second and third so
that, indeed, the last --
so there are now six would
have been in Congress.
And this is quite remarkable
since the first one, Jack Kennedy,
only got into Congress in 1947.
And again, there wouldn't be
a fifth and a sixth if Robert
and Ethel hadn't had 11 children.
So it all matches that way.
But again, part of that which is
fun if you actually get the book,
is the first volume ended not with
the Clintons, but with the Kennedys.
So what I did -- wherever it is --
[ Silence ]
Is I took the last page --
Of the first edition.
And the last page of the
first edition is right there.
And it says things like -- it goes
on so it features Robert F. Kennedy.
And then there's a line across, and
it says, "Robert Kennedy was killed
by sinking the democratic
presidential nomination June 6th,
1988."
The next is Ted.
As I write about them,
the line comes across,
"Ted Kennedy sought the democratic
presidential nomination in 1980,
and his loss is generally attributed
to the Chappaquiddick incident.
He died August 25, 1959."
Now, then we move across.
And as I talk about each person
as they would have
appeared 50 years ago,
the line brings them up to date.
"Joseph P. Kennedy born in 1952
was a member of the US House
of Representatives 1967 to nine.
He chose not to seek the
democratic gubernatorialship
in 1998 after a messy divorce."
The line goes across,
"Joseph 'John' F. Kennedy Jr.,
an inexperienced pilot died July
16, 1999 when his plane crashed
into the Atlantic near
Martha's Vineyard."
Move across, Kathleen; Kathleen.
Says, "Kathleen Kennedy Townsend was
lieutenant governor of Maryland,"
dates and then, "was defeated
when she ran for governor."
And it goes back to
Ethel Kennedy Shriver.
"Eunice Kennedy Shriver was the
founder of the Special Olympics.
She died August 11th, 2000 at 99."
And finally, the last has -- you
know, the end of the book has,
"Eunice Kennedy Shriver told the
Chicago Newspaper [inaudible] 1960,
'All we talk about is winning.'
Then she picked up her infant
son Tim, held him aloft,
and gently began to
indoctrinate, 'Win, win, win'."
That's the way the first book ends.
So we bring across to
Timothy, "Timothy Shriver,
chairman of the Special Olympics,
had never sought public office.
He has a PhD in education, he
is the author of 'Fully Alive:
Discovering What Matters
Most', about his work
with disabled veterans, in
which he devotes a chapter
to his Aunt Rosemary,
President Kennedy's sister,
and how their father, Joseph P.
Kennedy, Sr. had her lobotomized."
This thing is called "Ending in
Mid-Sentence," and the last sentence
of the new book is, "In the
Presidential election of 2016,
the American people elected -- ."
[Laughter] That's what
we do as historians.
We can't go beyond that.
So that's the way the book ends.
Yes?
>> [Inaudible] JFK's grandfather,
Fitzgerald [inaudible].
>> Stephen Hess: Oh, sure.
Yes, yes; they're all in
there, all of the Kennedys
from the day they got off the boat.
I had both cases, Kennedys and --
they're a fascinating family, yes.
>> John Cole: We have time
for a couple more questions,
and then we'll have
the book signing.
[ Silence ]
>> Yes, sir.
>> Stephen Hess: Yes.
>> What would you say [inaudible].
>> Stephen Hess: Say that -- what --
>> What would you say to inspiring
young authors today to [inaudible]?
>> Stephen Hess: I'm
sorry, I guess -- say --
>> What would you say to
inspiring young authors today
to follow their dreams?
>> Stephen Hess: To write
a book, or any book.
If it's in you, it doesn't need much
inspiration, but you sure need time,
and you need some space,
and it's awfully nice
if you have some mentoring, and if
you're at a place where the business
of the place is writing books,
as mine is at Brookings,
well they don't -- you know,
and give me the latitude
to write what I want to write about.
But I must admit, I've never
had any problem thinking
of what my next book would be.
So that's where you usually start.
And some books almost
write themselves.
You're lucky if that's it.
In some ways, the most
important book I did
in an academic sense was called
"Organizing the Presidency".
And it was a book -- after I had
been at the Nixon White House,
there was book in which I couldn't
figure out a way to make a Nixon
or a president a better man,
but I thought I could figure
out a better way for them
to organize themselves.
And so that book came out,
but it was all in my head.
So that was easy.
Other books you start
as I described this one,
and you don't even know what
you've written, in a funny way.
At least 50 years later, I
realized I'd written something else,
something I thought much
more important than I had set
out to write when I realized
that it was really the family
history of the United States.
Again, other books you're
told to write, if that's --
if you're in a place where that's
what they're paying you for.
I mean, I've written a number of
books on presidential transitions.
Well, that's -- I'm at
Brookings, that's what we do.
There's a transition, I've been
involved in them, I write a book.
But I really wouldn't worry
about wanting to write a book.
It's fun. I find it fun.
I don't -- wrote a
book with a person
who had terrible writer's
block; it wasn't fun at all.
But I've had fun at it, and I
highly recommend it to those
who had inclination to write.
>> John Cole: And the final
question is what is next?
>> Stephen Hess: You know,
the next is sort of weird.
The one before this was
very important to me.
I was -- Pat Moynihan my best
friend, and when he became,
strangely, the assistant to Richard
Nixon, the liberal been chosen
by a conservative for a very
important job as special
as the domestic affairs advisor,
and asked me to join
him, I could not resist.
And in that little
period, he and I --
while I'm sitting and then I created
the Family Assistance Program,
which was the most liberal piece of
legislation certainly ever proposed
by a Republican president.
And it's that story, the
story of the relationship
between Eisenhower --
between Nixon and Moynihan,
and it's called "The
President and the Professor:
Daniel Patrick Moynihan
and the Nixon White House".
So I got that off my chest.
I got it while Mrs.
Moynihan is still alive.
I wanted her to see
it, and that was it.
Now I'm trying something very weird.
I don't know whether I
can pull it off or not.
Brookings has a very
interesting podcast.
It's called "The Brookings
Cafeteria Podcast".
And it's sort of Ted-ish.
It's very elegant and long,
and the guy who designed it
decided he would interview me
and he would throw in, you know,
like two-minute Steve Hess stories.
He wanted to lighten his load.
And it worked pretty well.
I guess he thought I
was a good storyteller.
So together, what I'm doing
is really a conversational
political memoir.
And we sit down after I've laid
out all my documents and so forth,
and start telling the story.
And if we're lucky,
when it's edited,
it will sound like a
conversation, rather than a book.
At the least, we will have a Steve
Hess podcast, which we'll tell
through Eisenhower, and Nixon, and
Ford, and all of that sort of stuff.
If we're very lucky, it
will be a Brookings book
in which we can include
the documents.
If I go to a White House
dinner, there's the Bill affair,
if you will, and the pictures, and
the duck and so forth and so on.
It starts -- and the first question
he asks me is about my youth,
and goes into, you know, if I
have any political genes in me.
And I tell a little story
about my great aunt,
whose name was Belle Maskovitz
[assumed spelling], who was --
when she died in 1933, her
obituary in the New York Times said,
"The most powerful woman
politician in the United States."
And 3,000 people came
to her funeral.
She was basically a brain
behind Alfred E. Smith.
When he ran for president,
she was his advisor.
So, you know, I start with that
sort of thing, and move on and on
to I'm 11 years old and
I live on 96th Street
in Broadway in New -- 98th Street.
And I look down, and there's
Franklin Roosevelt driving
down Broadway in the rain in an open
car, the first president I ever saw.
and I'm 11 years old.
And I don't know that 96th Street
turns the corner, goes into garage,
has a rubdown, takes
some Cognac [phonetic].
And this is almost a historic
moment in American history.
It's the moment he was trying
to convince the American people
that he was healthy
enough to be reelected.
Of course, he's dead
four months later.
So it takes that.
Now I'm 19, and for some
reason, I'm in the midst
of the 1952 Eisenhower-Taft
Convention in Chicago.
Again, all stories, I was a
driver, but I got the group lost.
So and say they fired me and gave
me tickets to go to the convention
and I had a wonderful time.
So now -- so [inaudible]
I move onto that.
Now I'm 25, the story I
started to tell you I'm
in the White House,
again, by accident.
So it's a little like
a zelig [phonetic].
It's a little who is this person
who was never really a serious major
politician, always somehow seemed
to be in the right
place at the right time.
Why was I with Richard Nixon when
John Kennedy is assassinated,
you know, that sort
of story happens.
You know, or why am I dancing
with Jacqueline Kennedy?
You know, again, so [laughter]
that's -- read the next book.
I'll leave it there.
So that's what really what
I'm working on right now.
>> John Cole: Steve,
thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> Stephen Hess: Thank you.
>> John Cole: Thank you; and I
think you do have a political gene,
[laughter] something
that keeps you going.
That was wonderful, and you'll now
have a chance to talk with him more
and get a book signed, and think
a little bit about where we are
in our country in terms of both
the elections and dynasties.
And it's just really a
terribly interesting time.
And I know that you're going to
find a very interesting role somehow
as our country goes ahead with both
these dynasties, and with, you know,
what's ahead of us in a
very exciting election year.
I've left a list of other Center
for the Book talks
the rest of this year.
You've had two this week now on
politics, and so we're moving off
to some other topics, but
you're welcome to take that,
and to come back to
other events this year.
But in the meantime, let's get
your books signed and conclude
with another round of
applause for Steve Hess.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.